thanks to the groundbreaking work of the
Cameron Owens we know that cloning can
duplicate an individual from a single
genetic strand wow what my work explored
was the hopes of combining multiple
strands why are they just letting them
talk about this more Criminal
this is like Nazis talking about their
experiments in front of a bunch of the
world it's it's quite fast well you know
there's a lot of subscribers to that
kind of ideology that's true yes we're
listening we're like we're talking about
this now we have freedom of speech in
the new Republic now they can't arrest
us anymore that's right of course
shall we
mind if I stay
it's evil
he relapsed she's like hardcore evil I
still care about him
of course you do
yes you're welcome to stay
I just don't understand how they gave
them any of them Second Chances no and I
don't understand how that guy clearly is
like I'll leave you alone with the
ability to do whatever you want to him
well yes this moment for sure because
but that's
yeah they were fighting for Mob Gideon
10 years after the battle Avengers
exactly like these were like True
Believers yeah Fanatics these people
were just following orders there was a
new Republic that they could have worked
for and they chose to work for them they
could have deserted the Empire any time
after it's collapsed anybody they would
have been walking with open arms yeah no
these people had no no second chances
for these welcome back to new
rock stars and our John Favreau and Dave
filoni on a crusade to right the wrongs
of every past Star Wars movie if so dang
baby Eric Eric I was late I was late but
I'm I'm enthused it's because I'm still
so shook enough
understandably so what an interesting
episode yeah and we might be in a sequel
Redemption process right now it's a
difficult feeling we're going through
but I think we can trust Dave filoni and
John Favreau to do everything they can
to make us feel better about any era of
star absolutely this is the break room
presents Wookie links it's our weekly
Mandalorian after show and this week we
are talking about chapter 19 the convert
yeah this week we're back in our
respected blue dungeons because I caught
Tommy cranking the intensity of my mind
player and I don't want to be in the
same room as him anyway
it's just so tricky
you are just trying to zap the more like
uh triggering parts of my memories
that's right I want you to forget that
one cartel show we had in
2014.
but you know what that was the one show
where I actually had a good show Tom all
the other ones you had good shows that's
why like oh Eric had a fun second beat
tag in there I only want you to remember
my glory
I'm Eric Boss and my Easter egg
breakdown is coming tomorrow God willing
right now I'm here discussing this
episode with my best friend Tommy Beck
told yeah Tommy Eric so happy to see you
and I gotta be honest let's talk about
what the fet happened in this episode
did didn't do it Boca tan and grogu are
leaving the Living Waters but first Bo
has a quick question for Dan hey when I
was rescuing you or when you were
falling to your death did you see
anything in those Waters and he's like
only Redemption baby all I saw was sweet
sweet redemption and Bo's like sounds
good it let's get off this rock and
unfortunately that plan is interrupted
by Thai interceptors which did notes are
a lot more effective than Tie fighters
difficult to take out so they flee to
calvala and they defeat the first wave
of interceptors Eric but din gets his N1
ship back only to watch the second wave
of ship destroy that craze family castle
I have so many family memories uh oh
that poor servant Droid is yeah we're in
the rebel there I like to think he's
okay and maybe he's just gonna live
amongst the rubble with the little
animals but uh I I also think the
interesting thing is uh Beau mentions
that she scrugged off a lot of Warlords
in her time so I'm a little curious as
to what warlord is targeting targeting
her right now you know is it right and
why now yeah like why do they were they
following her back from Mandalore like
it was pretty if this is someone who had
an ax to grind with her yeah they kind
of chose right now to be part of her
place I agree so Bo Dan grogu and and
r4d5 who really had a tough goal of it
in his minimal scene time today the
Escape into a mysterious hyperspace
coordinates meanwhile on Coruscant Dr
Pershing has joined the new Republic
amnesty program and is giving a speech
as part of his Rehabilitation and in
that speech he's explaining how they
could just do the old things the empire
did to make things to make the new
Republic great again what a bizarre
speech uh oh just a bizarre context of
it like I understand like big picture
they're trying to fill in the gaps of of
the sequel and we'll talk about that
more but they're trying to like set up
the sequel Trilogy in the first order
yeah but like was this part of his
Rehabilitation or just like was his
parole officer like okay fine you can do
this like I just think it's so weird
that a that a new Republic who banned
cloning would allow a former Nazi to
come out in front of everyone and say
like hey but here's the Eugenics stuff
we were trying to do actually and how it
was actually a good thing right like I I
understand that his mom needed a heart
transplant but like does it need to be a
TED Talk also my my thing Eric is and
we'll get into it is like how much do
you really believe any of these people
anyway like did his mom need a heart
transplant is Acadia brand schedule
he tugged his ear which tells us that
he's telling the truth like you cannot
tell a lie he's talking his ear it
doesn't seem like the most obvious poker
tell in the world like almost like wink
wink yeah finger on the nose when I tug
my belly button that's when I'm hungry
all right anyway Katie O'Brien's
character who we're going to call comms
officer until later in this in this
recap because that's her name until for
now she was the comms officer in moff
Gideon ship she watches on kind of
interested Dr Pershing arrives at the
amnesty housing and chats was about the
good old days with some of the other
recovering bad guys and they're all like
man don't you miss the food sometimes
remember when we were just wiping out
planets for no reason remember that
giant Death Star destroyed Alderaan that
was a lot of fun anyway I mean how how
bad are things in the new Republic if
they're nostalgic for the Empire right
like everything that we've seen in Star
Wars is that people who are like forced
to fight for the Empire or like are
drafted aren't having a good time what
they're talking about are these kids
bits that have like these freeze-dried
food in it right you have to imagine at
least being in like in whatever the Hong
Kong of the universe yeah whatever we
want to call Coruscant the Singapore the
New York City the London like the food's
got to be at least a bit better than
just getting like freeze-dried packs
absolutely biscuits absolutely but then
again we are currently living in a
society that's like Nixon and Reagan
were actually pretty good presidents
anyway I think that's what it is I think
it's all an indictment on the new
Republic it's just how bad the nodes so
we see the doctor and the comms officer
taking a stroll through George Lucas's
mind AKA downtown Florissant this
episode to me was the second time so far
in this early season that we've seen
them just be like let's paint a picture
that's going to make George Lucas go oh
boy
there were all sorts of CGI aliens there
were uh I want to get this right Photon
fizzes proton fizzes
Eric let me take you out for a proton
Fizz sometime um yeah I think you and I
were forced to drink as many proton
physics as we could during Fitness
Origins that's right we just had to just
chug those down until that was the plan
and that's why I still cry Tears of
Blood now at his job Dr Pershing has
been demoted to just a simple archivist
the comms officer Katie O'Brien once
again convinces Dr Pershing to continue
his research as they head to a shipyard
to go get him some supplies to do so
Tong days am I right Eric
I yeah I think the whole I was very
fascinated by this Arc and specifically
The Twist of it when you go back to
re-watch it yeah because now I'm just
wondering did the New Republic keep
these Imperial shipyards there just to
lure in Old nostalgic war criminals so
that they can like say gotcha there's
some sort of a pack of jail there's some
new Republic Chris Harrison it's like
can you have a seat can I talk to you
for a second
can you have a seat do you understand
what you were doing why do you got to
pack some money why you gotta well you
got a six pack of Mike Hard Lemonade
there uh anyway some of those damn
ticket droids are making things
difficult so perishing in the comms have
to leap off the train conveniently right
onto a star destroyer with the things
they need I do love stuff well again
again they leap off the train did these
new Republic in trapping amnesty
um parole officer set up a mattress
there yeah just to be like okay and then
you'll jump right here and you'll both
survive all right Droids on the train
will move real slow as to not arrest you
like do you have been all very
convenient given how devious this comms
officer who now gets a name Elia Kane is
I have no doubt that this whole thing
was elaborately planned by her I mean
she seems as evil as MAF Gideon uh she's
done this before yeah she's she's got
like uh the record in the new amnesty
offices of people of like yeah she's
like they're gonna stop us yeah exactly
she's she's dogged Bounty Hunter for
this but so anyway she says her name's
Elia King but how could we possibly know
that because everything she said has
been revealed to be a lie or at least
something to set up Dr Pershing who is
arrested now the amnesty program plans
on giving him just a light little mental
reset until Kane turns the Mind flare up
to 11 and seems pretty pleased with
herself doing it she takes a little
celebratory biscuit bite she's like hell
yeah I just uh the only person who
showed me kindness in the last 15 years
is now uh scrambled eggs and tossed
salad uh anyway because he just got mind
flashered meanwhile Dan and Beau with
grogu in tow which is my uh is what I
would call my children's book about the
Mandalorian didn't Bo with groco and toe
arrive at the at Mando's old Mandalorian
covert and he has been redeemed baby
everybody celebrates except past Visa
who I assume looks like this under his
helmet
yep with the real like uh beautifully
waxed mustache of Tate Fletcher who I'm
I may be wrong but they I don't know if
they've ever credited John Favre as the
voice but here they discredited the
entire character as possibly or as Tate
Fletcher Tate Fletcher's always been
doing the physical performance of the
character I think at this point he's
also doing the voice okay which is great
for Tate fledge yeah because the guy can
the guy can talk as well right as put on
a hell of a physical performance I agree
and I and I and I love that character
just a scout massive Mandalorian
speaking of stout and massive Eric we're
wearing some comfortable shirts that are
available over at our merch Partners at
nerdriot.shop they have some great new
Mandalorian inspired items in their new
the way collection including uh the
foundling shirt and a shirt called The
Bounty Hunter with designs inspired by
the best car steals of Mandalore if you
purchase one of these shirts you can opt
to unlock a shout out on this show like
this one from Mark Bell R.I.P CAD Bane
more this one from Jacob Rickard best
Mandalorian Seasons yet love everyone at
new rock stars oh thanks buddy yeah we
appreciate that Jacob now visit
nerdright.shop to grab one of these
great designs and don't take it off
until the finale in two months be like
me no showers no close changes no
relationships no happiness
all right Tommy what is the first
question we're asking here does the
amnesty program just a Sleeper Cell for
the first order is this like the first
order is origin story somehow Palpatine
returned finally explained yes I mean it
looks to be the case there and I like
I'm interested to see where they go with
this for sure
um I think it's a very bold and ballsy
move by Dave filonia's team to even
touch that third rail of Star Wars
fandom but if anybody can do it they can
yeah uh like this whole I mean that's
now a meme now of like somehow Palpatine
yes returned from from the rise of
Skywalker we know cloning was involved
but you know this also seemed to be
something they were planning to do from
the first season it's not like he he
turned the the first episode of the
Mandalorian introduced grogu and that
came out uh what about a month before
the rise of Skywalker did so we know
that this was always part of the plan
it's just been interesting to see this
season the mandalorians suddenly take
that turn because the very the first two
episodes seemed holy about the
Mandalorian mythology and their culture
their rituals and their Traditions but I
think that kind of if you look at the
first two seasons and then the first two
episodes it they one thing they do is
they take their time getting to the
getting to these like uh kind of filling
in the gaps of of what led to the
sequels you know it's like the first
season obviously we get some information
we get that we get grogu we get the kind
of all the things with uh what's his
name Rena hertzog's character it's like
we learned that there's something up
second season I think is when we finally
see the Clone facility right and we see
all the weird kind of
um half made yeah the pre-snoke yeah
by the way kids are smoking pre-snoke on
the streets these days guys don't do it
you're gonna get popcorn lung uh so
anyway
yeah I think I think that one thing that
they do in order to kind of like they're
doing this repair slowly this is a slow
or not repair but I can be repair sounds
cynical but like they are they're
filling in the gaps and making the the
sequel experience perhaps more of uh
something that makes sense to Star Wars
fans with with a thousand little moves
rather than just one giant scroll
that literally says somehow Palpatine
returned you know or yeah or Oscar Isaac
just drops the line I mean poor Oscar
that guy did great work yes in those
three films yes his legacy his legacy is
reduced yeah to just that those three
words again if anybody can do it Dave
filoni can and like I think as much as
some sections of the fandom don't like
the sequel Trilogy I think everyone
forgets how much a lot of people did not
like the prequel trilogy and how much
now we can look back at those movies and
appreciate them for all the great things
they did as a result of what filoni did
and his team did in Clone Wars I really
think that they can do this here I think
the reason why some people maybe react
it's interesting that people say they
this is like the an Andor episode I'm
like I don't know if you really got
Andover because I find Andrew to be very
interesting I understand it's not for
everyone but like what the reason I
react the way I do to this episode is it
just feels so abrupt like I understand
if they want to jump away to like Jedi
mythology and grogu's origin is the
relationship with Luke Skywalker and
Ahsoka but to jump back to the cloning
stuff so abruptly literally we cut to
Black away from Mando yeah you're right
this is like in a it doesn't even do a
like Star Wars fade across like right
yeah they're just like they they they
section they go but I will say
thematically it does still work because
we jump to the the Mandalorian and then
the convert so the whole episode you're
wondering well who is the convert of the
episode well by the episode's end it's
Pokemon for sure she's been converted or
at least they're welcoming her yeah into
the children they're telling us yeah
you're like no you are you didn't mean
to but you've been baptized so welcome
to the church baby congratulations
that wasn't rain that was someone
outside the church sprinkling holy water
on you my friend but I think there's a
way to look at it the the convert theme
to to uh Dr Penn Pershing as well like
in kind of a grim Outlook where he was
forcibly held down and zapped with the
Mind flayer and that in a way like he
was kind of brought in you you're
watching it like oh is is there going to
be some turn where Kane's turns to him
and says hey actually I'm working for
this cool guy yeah
he's Palpatine yeah or he's thrawn or
something like that like you're gonna
find out that she's part of it and she
might still be in fact it seems like she
is when she dials up that thing that she
just wants to cover all of her tracks is
that how we should look at that moment
where she uh raised the Mind flayer to
11 that she just doesn't want any other
witnesses that can be traced back to to
Palpatine well yeah right now I think
the reason you think about that or the
reason that makes sense is when uh when
Pershing gets to that table where the
other three amnesty program guys are and
then he sees uh he sees Kane he's like
hey I didn't expect to see anyone else
who worked for moff Gideon and the three
of them were like oh we had no idea so
obviously she's not being forthcoming
with what she did for the Empire right
so I think she saw that as like this guy
around with full mental power uh is
compromising me kind of moving in the
shadows you know trying to set things up
yeah I am just impressed that uh that
Kane is able to get to this position
where she can be like a double agent for
the new Republic right and uh like
obviously when everyone got arrested
when Moth Gideon went down anybody who
was associated with him also got
arrested and that includes uh officer
Kane and that includes Dr Pershing
um what is interesting is that she was
able to cut this side deal in the time
that Dr Pershing was still being hunted
down or processed and she like she
seemed to have this like a history with
the new Republic uh and that she is able
to do this like masad
didn't hire a former SS right right you
know like it's just such a there's no
history yeah it's a really weird turn
now do you think that like you know in
the I don't know how space law works but
getting him to ask you know getting him
to ask that or Intergalactic or you know
Star Wars law Works do you think the
idea of getting him to ask that robot
kind of counselor like is it okay is it
unethical or allowed am I allowed to do
my own research was a way to get like a
warrant to like set him up like she
needed him to ask that question in an
appropriate capacity because to me it
was like why do they show us that scene
other you know if not for that end
result you know like if that was going
to be the end result showing that scene
didn't really seem necessary so it's
like to me I'm like are we getting into
like the like this is how you set people
up in the in the in the new Republic is
you have to get them to start openly
saying they might do something bad and
then you get you have carte blanche to
entrap them either the new public is
extremely smart and sophisticated or
extremely dumb and incompetent based off
of this episode yeah either they have
orchestrated everything Dr person has
been going through in his parole Loop
including his Ted Talk including all of
his interviews with his uh Droid parole
officer
um the little one-on-ones he has with
his boss in the archive room
um all the little side chatter he has in
the courtyard of the amnesty housing
probably that taxi Droid who's telling
him all these Star Wars Legends Easter
eggs of the the Sky Dome botanical
gardens yes
um the malistar yeah like all this stuff
either they have orchestrated all that
and they are listening to everything
every micro expression that he has
looking for tells that he might still be
trying to replicate his cloning research
or they are extremely dumb and
incompetent in letting someone like this
looping him back into into the new
Republic culture this whole amnesty
program is insane yeah like it'd be one
thing if several years had passed and
then everyone who worked for the empire
was rounded up arrested facing their own
Nuremberg trials and this is just
something that we did for the ones who
really were just following orders but
we're talking about ones who just in the
previous year 10 years after the battle
of Endor are continuing yeah to to tow
the Empire line yeah and continuing to
do horrifying we're firing on Navarro to
try and steal Grogan with Photon games
right and are proudly out in the public
bragging about the now about that the
night of a thousand Tears In The Purge
it's just I don't understand the logic
of this like it just feels like we're
moving right past it I can't reconcile
it
um but I I'm for now willing to accept
that at least within the new Republic
um Elia Kane is so sophisticated and
that he and that person was targeted for
a specific reason yeah I just don't know
if the new Republic targeted him it
seems like the new Republic had their
eye on him right and and uh maybe from
the moment of his Ted Talk they're like
oh let's keep an eye on this guy and see
if we can lure him back into it but it
seems like the entrapment was something
done by Kane to get his research sure
she held on to that stuff oh do you
think the new Republic would book it
back into evidence and that they would
have some kind of investigation and
wouldn't let her go home with that that
she'd be left alone with this guy I'm
ranting right now Tommy Talk me off the
ledge no I think I think what you're
saying makes sense I think all will be
revealed
you know what I'm about to reveal
a perfect smile because good health
starts with good habits Eric and quip
makes it Easy by delivering all the Oral
Care Essentials you need to care for
that mouth
their electric toothbrush has timed
Sonic vibrations to keep going as long
as Dennis recommend you brush so you
don't have to worry about it if you're
doing enough you know for me I always
said my rule was one scrub up top one
scrub down below and that's it well I've
got some quick toothpaste Eric look at
this now if you go to getquip.com break
room right now you get 20 off any quick
water flosser equipped toothbrush or
quips gum starter pack that's 20 off any
water floss or toothbrush or gum starter
kit at getquip.com break room that's g e
t q u i p.com slash break room quick the
good habits company and we also want to
thank Turbo Tax go to Turbo Tax and
don't do your taxes meet with an expert
who will do them for you Turbo Tax
experts can relieve you from the stress
of taxes and file for you so you can do
not taxes show your eyes things that are
not taxes unpack a moving box of not
taxes taste not taxes sing not tax is a
lullaby hope not taxes sleeps through
the night grab a saddle and ride not
taxes into the sunset with Turbo Tax an
expert will do your taxes from start to
finish ensuring your taxes are done
right guaranteed so you can relax feels
good to be done with your taxes doesn't
it come to TurboTax and don't do your
taxes visit turbotax.com to learn more
Intuit TurboTax full service products
only video meeting well where expert
does your taxes required to see
guaranteed details at turbotax.com
guarantees Eric Tommy let me get back to
the episode yeah who the fact do we
think attacked Boca 10. are you thinking
thrawn am I thinking thrawn are we going
thrawn here I hope it's thrawn uh in
fact I would have loved to have spent
more time in this episode I think
structurally is it am I just
overthinking it that maybe they had a
whole purchasing episode and then when
they were looking at it in the edit
they're like
I think viewers might be a little torn
if we just spend an entire episode in
this Pershing plot let's bumper it and
end it with some great Mando action all
right undeniably people will be happy at
the beginning and then happy at the end
I think so I don't think that the
Goodwill that was met with Bando and
grogu and Luke and Ahsoka appearing in
Boba Fett would be reciprocated when
those beloved characters were then taken
out of an entire episode of Mandalorian
you know what I mean like I feel like I
feel like that door opens one way I
think it's
um it's either moff Gideon if he did
actually Escape because there was that
line later in the episode where they're
like oh is he taking the Mind player I
heard he escaped
um it's either mop Gideon Gathering his
resources I think it'd be a little soon
for that to happen
um or it's thrawn
um because she was she said she had
ripped off or skugged off she said
skugged off a couple uh Imperial
Warlords yeah uh but this one seems like
personal the fact that they bombed her
home Castle
she was surprised she was like no
Imperial warlord has that big of a fleet
right now except thron yeah thrawn was
the one behind this yeah well that makes
sense and so what do we think is
bocatan's next move how long do you
think she's gonna stay with the covert I
think now that she knows the din I'm
sorry to ask you a question that
immediately answer it uh but that's just
how I do things here on Tommy Talks uh I
feel like now that she knows din did not
see the mythosaur she is currently
enacting a plan to take over as the
ruler of Mandalore and the Mandalorian
so I don't think that any conversion
that is happening here is authentic or
long-standing I think it's probably
she'll stay there as long as she needs
to formulate a plan or maybe get some
Communications out to some allies yeah
you know what this is she is
infiltrating the cult right now she's
not a True Believer batshit Orthodoxy
right she is essentially Daniel
Plainview and There Will Be Blood
infiltrating Eli's church just to get
oil drilling rights on that land that's
all she wants she doesn't drink the
Kool-Aid she doesn't care she drinks she
knows that he is a false prophet
admitted you are a false prophet and
then she's gonna drink their milkshake
of all that fluid
just gonna get a long shot and drink all
the Living Waters
is thirsty she's thirsty she is thirsty
ooh and I'm thirsty for her now do we
think muff Gideon escaped with the Lion
King's help is he still at large or did
a lion king fry his brain the way she
Zapped version uh yeah I don't oh to
think that she actually
uh turned in her like because I go back
and forth yes it'd be one thing if we
get Giancarlo Esposito back in here and
I think it would just be kind of
replaying season 1 and season two if if
yeah just comes back uh and is is
re-gathered his resources it would make
him the ultimate big bad of the series
right uh my hope is that like hey Sean
Carlos playing Professor X right now for
the MCU and he's busy he's got no time
to appear on Star Wars at the same time
uh and that they introduce thrawn as a
big bad or some part of the Mandalorian
cult ideology as the villain of the
series yeah that would be my hope uh
however I also think that it'd be more
interesting I mean if it makes if ellia
Kane zap doctor Zapped MAF Gideon and
brought him to the Mind flayer that
would make that would really Elevate her
status as a as a villain right now I
don't know she's pretty evil I mean that
you know the last sure five minutes of
that sequence when she turns on him just
her eyes the way she's looking at him
with so much like contempt and like it
doesn't look like there's any remorse at
all all really I mean she kind of is
like can I speak candidly um I I think
all the actors they bring on these shows
definitely bring something to the table
to the table I'm really excited for them
uh and to see their Futures when people
compare this to and or the reason why
that comparison falls apart is when
every episode of mandor every actor they
hired on that show Diego Luna Stellan
Skarsgard Fiona Shaw we were watching
like Shakespearean level actors just
have fascinating dialogue yeah I don't
know if I needed to sit with these two
actors for 36 minutes sure I didn't find
them that compelling look I think Katie
O'Brien is an amazing performer I think
some of the stunt work she can do I
think the physical work she can do is
great they put her in this very
restrained role and I think she was
making some interesting acting choices
but overall like it I didn't like seeing
spycraft from these two characters yeah
it feels like we have enough spycraft
already in in in the uh Disney plus Star
Wars shows so it's like adding a
spycraft element to what is kind of of
the ultimate space Western show right
now is like all right well I I agree I
also think I agree like I think the
direction for her when she was supposed
to be playing like reformed amnesty uh
participant was a lot of like I won't
allow myself to really feel anything
like I'm just like right okay here's
some biscuits I'm friendly but also like
I mean she was kind of honeypotting him
right yeah yeah like that was a bit of a
Honeypot maneuver where she's like I'll
bring you your biscuits hey come find me
in the courtyard yeah it was me who gave
you those biscuits and like I just
didn't really buy it from this and I
don't really blame the actor so much as
I blame the writing I just think the
character was written to be so weird on
what exact and yes there's some mystery
to the character but then once we find
out what the characters real intentions
are it doesn't line up with like the
logic of the world and what we saw them
do throughout throughout the episode
yeah it's just either two e again the
new Republic is either in like
insanely insanely conspiratorial and and
4D testing all of this in a way that
doesn't really seem realistic or they're
just incredibly stupid that also seems
to be I mean I guess maybe that's the
agenda of all this is just paint the new
Republic it's just like so easily
subverted any kind of interest and
that's why the first order was able to
rise I I know I know yeah exactly as I
say we're I know we're we're talking it
you were talking around it but it's like
yeah I mean why else was the Empire
basically able to return with with new
emblems in a new name you know it's like
oh right it's the alert don't learn from
your past Doom to repeat it but it's
like they were doomed to repeat it so
quickly it was like right and they did
have that line of like oh they're
dismantling the military
um decommissioning the military yeah
which we know what's the case I mean
that was why uh Leia kind of broke off
in the political factions I just like it
we we just saw that
era of the new Republic from just such
an interesting angle that I don't it was
not like when we saw the the Imperial
era from the from Anders angle we saw it
from almost this like Game of Thrones
level tiered system or the wire where
you see the top level brass who are
doing spycraft we see the grunts and the
trenches who are uh pulling up these
heists
um we see the Imperial investigators we
got a sense of why the empire was doing
what it was doing and how cruel and
inhumane it was here we're just seeing
it from this one kind of closed off
Place yeah it feels like we're watching
1984 a little bit where a character is
like he meets someone but he doesn't
know if it's like a spy who he can trust
um also it'd be one thing if like we
were excited for Pershing to be
successful but like he's also a guy
who's like a cloner who was
experimenting on grogu to bring about
snoke like there's just so many things
that we're not rooting for in this
equation that it's kind of hard to just
like know who who we're rooting for
right now yeah and it's not like an and
or where we're watching a bunch of bad
characters do bad things or watching The
Last of Us uh like morally compromised
characters because at least in those
situations we we can kind of like say
well if I were in that situation I would
do this when I watch this episode I'm
like if I were in that situation I would
I would be one of the guys in the
courtyard just continuing to talk about
biscuits
exactly I'm with you I've been eating
I'd just be with you eating proton
fizzes Eric that's it just you and me
holding hands walking through Coruscant
watching that magician guy make a bird
come out of his uh out of his
handkerchief hey we saw that courtyard
before right didn't Obi-Wan it's a team
go on a date in that courtyard that's
right I know I heard the resistance
music they turned the resistant March of
the resistance theme into like a
carnival March like which that was fun
yeah Easter eggs on this episode were on
point yeah I'll give you that we're
gonna get the team yeah yeah I'm working
on that uh hopefully that will be able
to come out tomorrow
so at least to pull apart from that
angle um so we'll leave it there for
this episode of WikiLeaks hey I know I
was hard on this episode so but you know
what I I love I love everything that
Dave filoni is doing with Star Wars and
I and I'm again I'm giving him the
benefit of the doubt I'm excited to see
where he's going and I'm happy for him
to take this hard task of trying to make
sense of the logic of the sequel Trilogy
at least in the later of installments of
the single Trilogy
um and again my Easter egg breakdown is
coming tomorrow you can follow me at the
avos you can follow Tommy at Tommy back
told we'll be back next week to react to
episode four and of course the break
room is live every day on the rock stars
at 3 P.M and uh hey if you don't mind
please subscribe to the Deep dive this
week we're going to be diving into John
Wick it's a really fun video follow new
Rockstar subscribe to WikiLeaks wherever
you get your podcasts thanks for
watching and this this is the way
that's how Grogan says it
foreign